well America isn't the only country with
a major political split over the
question of who comes in and under what
circumstance it's not the only country
where its leaders baldly lie to its own
people about the effects of that
immigration yesterday for example in
Sweden a police station was hit by a
grenade attack that's more common than
it has been explosive attacks have well
exploded in the past few years as Sweden
has welcomed a massive number of
immigrants into its once famously placid
society this has caused a lot of effects
some of them political we recently spoke
to a man called Hanif Bali he's an
Iranian immigrant to Sweden who may be
unlikely as it is has become a leader a
celebrated one in the push for tougher
immigration laws there watch what is the
problem with Sweden's immigration system
now so there are many problems it's very
hard to define one but the biggest
problem is the amount of immigrants that
are coming in in the last couple of
years we have taken in about 250,000
asylum seekers and for comparison that
would be like America taking in about 8
or 9 million asylum seekers this is
people that Sweden provides housing
health care schooling and all these big
a lot of these expensive services that
the Swedish welfare system gives to
people and this has creative course a
lot of huge costs in the short run for
the Swedish system but also when we look
at long term but we're seeing now with
crime and poverty is effects of having a
very lacks migration system for 10-15
years ago and what we're seeing now with
with basically ghettos and street gangs
which is a phenomenon that haven't been
never even heard of it Sweden and also
jihadists traveling abroad etc these are
problems that are new to Sweden the
Sweden's system is not capable of you
know it's not capable and it's not
defined
handle these problems for example in
unemployment I mean in 2006 about 20% of
people unemployed were immigrants and
foreign-born today that number is up to
60% so you are an immigrant from a
Muslim family and you've taken a hard
line against Muslim immigration mass
immigration from Muslim countries what's
the response been to you if we want to
help people and that is truly what we
want to do you cannot put so much
pressure to the system that the per that
the system collapse under its own weight
and the response I've been having to
because I'm you know merely putting this
statement out that saying look there's a
limit to how many people you can you can
take in has been to call me basically
uncle tom house Nick I've been compared
to dr. mengele you know the the the and
this is not from random people on the
street these are people will have
prominent posts in in parties in in the
left in newspapers and and this is of
course because I don't you know I don't
tell them that the wishful thinking that
they want to hear yes well we're very
familiar with that in this country
you're a brave man and we wish you luck
thank you for joining us Jane thank you